es ist die nachricht über die heute ganz
deutschland spricht nicht weniger als
eine zeitenwende in der korona politik
gestern abend erst bei bild live
verkündet der künftige kanzler olaf
scholz will eine allgemeine impfpflicht
einführen scholz stellte sich den
hartnäckigen fragen von paul ronzheimer
wie will er die pandemie besiegen hier
sehen wir ihnen wie er ankommt am axel
springer hochhaus in berlin wird es neue
lok bei uns geben und brauchen wir eine
impfpflicht ja das war seine wichtigste
antwort und damit gibt es jede menge
gesprächsstoff deshalb ist bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer heute morgen bei uns
genommen
jan vielleicht hören wir uns als erstes
die zentrale aussage von olaf scholz in
dem großen exklusiven bild live
interview von gestern abend noch mal
kurz angefordert sprechen
da wo menschen ganz besonders geschützt
werden müssen den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen krankenhäuser
müssen die beschäftigten sich impfen
lassen und gleichzeitig brauchen wir für
einen zeitpunkt im nächsten jahr das
kann vom februar das kann anfang märz
sein die aussage bis dahin sollten sich
aber alle geimpft haben denn meine idee
mein vorschlag ist ja dass der zeitpunkt
bis zu dem dann jeder und jede sich
haben impfen lassen auch nicht allzu
fern liegt also mein vorschlag anfang
februar oder anfang märz da wo ja das
ist eine 180 grad kehrtwende noch im
september hatte olaf scholz gesagt
impfpflicht brauchen wir nicht jetzt
kann man sagen gut er hat gelernt die
zeiten haben sich geändert oder man kann
sagen wieder einmal versprechen
versprochen gebrochen also es geht ja
nicht nur um olaf scholz in dieser frage
es gibt viele politiker auch markus
söder beispielsweise auch der fdp
vorsitzende christian lindner die in den
letzten wochen eine kehrtwende vollzogen
haben weil sie bisher eigentlich immer
auch öffentlich gesagt haben soll keine
impfpflicht keine allgemeine impfpflicht
geben das ist aber offenbar angesichts
der zahlen die wir jetzt sehen nicht nur
ins identen aber auch aus vitalisierung
raten etwas was sich die künftige
bundesregierung die ampelkoalition nicht
mehr bieten lassen möchten deswegen
rückt sie von diesem nein zur
allgemeinen impfpflicht aber am ende
muss man sagen scholz und seine neue
regierung die stehen ja vor einem
dilemma entweder
lockdown wieder ein lock down oder eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wenn man es auf
diesen kurzen nenner bringt das ist eine
entscheidung zwischen pest und cholera
beides absolute sprengkraft natürlich
für die gesellschaft hat und olaf scholz
hat sich wahrscheinlich aber die
umfragen angeschaut hat festgestellt es
gibt eine deutliche mehrheit für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht in deutschland
und dann nimmt er möglicherweise einfach
den einfacheren weg und sagt sich ok
locker und will ich auf jeden fall
verhindern schulschließungen auch
deswegen die allgemeine und gestern
wurde ja bereits in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
beziehungsweise bei dem koma wie gipfel
quasi verkündet dass es eben ein locker
und er dann für ungeimpfte geben wird
bis dahin bis eben diese allgemeine
impfpflicht gelten soll aber es wurde ja
nicht nur über das impfen gesprochen bzw
nicht nur über die impfpflicht denn auch
über den impfschutz wie lange dieser
gelten soll wir können auch noch einmal
reingucken weiß olaf scholz da genau bei
uns gesagt hat hier zum impfschutz
wir wissen auf alle fälle dass die
jetzige dass der vollständige impfschutz
mit zwei impfungen anders als gehofft im
frühjahr zum beispiel
nicht die wirkung hat dass er für so
lange zeit reicht und deshalb ist es
jetzt ja so wichtig dass viele
bürgerinnen bürger sich anstellen was
sie machen und sich ärgern darüber dass
es nicht gut genug klappt brauchen wir
ein dauerabo sprich ohne bus dann geht
nichts mehr offenbar ist es das was ja
auch experten sagen dass der impfschutz
aufgrund von neuen corona varianten die
auftreten nicht mehr so voll umfänglich
ist wie man das noch vor ein paar
monaten eigentlich geglaubt hat und dann
ist es natürlich logisch auch zu sagen
wer wirklich den vollen schutz haben
will der braucht die booster impfung das
ist ganz klar wenn ich einmal den punkt
noch mal machen darf in sachen lockdown
oder auch impfen allgemeine impfpflicht
booster impfung dann ist es schon
praktisch gar nicht schlecht von olaf
scholz diesen weg diesen lockt da und
auch den schul lockdown auszuschließen
zumindest ist ja dass seine strategie
der zeit denn nichts ist schlimmer für
eine koalition eine regierung die neu
startet den kompletten frust
abzubekommen also eine wirtschaft die
wieder abstürzt wir sehen jetzt schon
die prognosen dass das
wirtschaftswachstum schlechter wird dass
die wirtschaft vielleicht sogar
schrumpfen wird
dann wieder schülerinnen und schüler die
nichts lernen weil sie zu hause sitzen
das muss man hier einfach auch zu sagen
homeschooling heißt eigentlich oder
weniger nichts lernen das ist eine
verwaltung dann aber kein aktives lernen
so und diesem dilemma befindet sich olaf
scholz die neue regierung und da kommt
dann noch hinzu dass er sagt wir müssen
auch schneller insgesamt das impf tempo
erhöhen um eine boost technologie dritte
impfung voranzubringen das ist der punkt
wie soll das logistische funktionieren
scholz hat gesagt er möchte bis
weihnachten 30 millionen zusätzliche
impfungen haben das sind also mehr als
eine million am tag das sind
spitzenwerte die wir im juni hatten ich
glaube gestern hatten wir 500.000
impfungen also wir sind weit davon
entfernt und wir haben beim boostern die
langen schlangen vor den impfzentren
gesehen auch dazu hat olaf scholz sich
geäußert wäre noch mal
wenn sie sagen möglicherweise alle sechs
monate und jetzt den beschlagen wo drei
stunden vier stunden die menschen warten
müssen auf den impfstoff das kommt bei
den bürgerinnen und bürgern so an dass
sie sich darüber ärgern dass nicht alles
flutscht und deshalb ist es ja richtig
zu sagen wir können jetzt nicht einfach
so weitermachen wir brauchen einen neuen
anfang der aber wie soll er aussehen
dieser neu anfangen ja und da kommt
etwas zum ausdruck was bemerkenswert
dass olaf scholz versucht jetzt ganz
klar eigentlich sich als der neue
kanzler zu positionieren damit dem was
die regierung davor in der ware immer in
vizekanzler getan hat eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so viel zu tun hat ja die
menschen ärgern sich darüber dass sie
sich so richtig flutscht das muss jetzt
besser werden also olaf scholz ist ja
mitverantwortlich dafür dass es nicht
richtig flott und die 30 millionen
booster impfung das ist jetzt keine
garantie von ihm gewesen das war aber
eine eine ein wunsch den er geäußert
meine prognose ist der wird nicht
erfüllt werden können denn das würde
bedeuten dass man eigentlich weit mehr
als zehn millionen menschen jetzt pro
woche war noch drei wochen bis
weihnachten haben sagen wir mal impfen
müsste das wird so schnell nicht gehen
und auch die hoffnung dass die apotheker
plötzlich mit nicht kennen jetzt selbst
apotheker die jubeln und das ist jetzt
ironisch gemeint die sagen wir wissen
gar nicht wie wir das schaffen sollten
jetzt eigentlich auch noch zu impfen
also vielleicht sollte auch jemand
vorher mit den apothekern sprechen ich
glaube das ziel 30 millionen ist nicht
haltbar wenn man der zahnärzte verband
hat sich heute angeboten und hat gesagt
wir sind bereit mit zu impfen könne
vielleicht auch schon mal ein wenig
helfen ja bis es soweit ist sollen dann
die zweijährige gelten das heißt
ungeimpfte werden vom öffentlichen leben
wirklich weitgehend ausgeschlossen beim
einkaufen in den supermärkten
restaurants gastronomie und so weiter
und so fort haben wir uns noch mal an
was olaf scholz dazu gesagt hat hätten
wir eine höhere impfquote hätten wir
eine andere lage und weil wir sie nicht
haben müssen wir dazu beitragen dass das
sich ändert wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass die kontakte der ungeimpften
sehr beschränkt werden auch darüber ist
diskutiert worden wir werden da wo die
inzidenz sehr hoch sind wo das
ansteckungsgefahr sehr sehr intensiv ist
dafür sorge tragen müssen dass dann auch
clubs und diskotheken nicht einfach auf
bleiben können
ja wir erleben ein retro winter das kann
man glaube ich schon so sagen das sind
alles dinge die wir vor einem jahr
genauso diskutiert haben und es kam dann
auch genauso clubs bars wurden
geschlossen es gab dann nur noch die
möglichkeit da waren wir alle noch
ungeimpft in supermärkte zu gehen und
dort einzukaufen alle anderen geschäfte
waren geschlossen wir erleben genau das
jetzt wieder wie erleben die kontakt
beschränkung wenn man manuela schwesig
die ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern heute morgen hört dann sagt
die sogar dass wir auch als geimpfte
wieder mit kontakt beschränkungen
rechnen müssen dass es kontakt
beschränkung für geimpfte geben sollte
das bedeutet also wir steuern voll auf
diesen diesen winter zu den wir
eigentlich schon einmal erlebt hat jetzt
in hamburg wer die hospitalisierung des
instituts gar nicht so hoch ist ich
glaube wärmen gestern auf die zahlen
geguckt wer da war hamburg zumindest mit
im grünen bereich aber selbst da gilt
jetzt ja seit neuestem zweig bzw die
zweige plus regel denn in einigen oder
an einigen orten also selbst da wird es
jetzt eben einschränkungen geben obwohl
da eben die lage gar nicht so dramatisch
ist wie haben sich sonst die
ministerpräsidenten gestern dazu
geäußert vielleicht sogar noch was zu
sagen also die sitzung verlief durchaus
harmonisch ab kann man sagen sie war
auch nicht deutlich kürzer als in den
vorangegangenen corona gipfeln oder mit
den franken und den crooner gipfeln der
fall war und drei stunden hat man
debattiert aber was auffällig ist dass
aus dem süden sehr viel kritik am
vorgehen insgesamt und an den geplanten
maßnahmen kam also gerade markus söder
das was wir hören hat immer wieder
aufgefordert eine bundes notbremse
einzuführen ebenfalls natürlich sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann und auch
winfried kretschmann der grüne
ministerpräsident wird mir also die drei
aus dem süden die machen ordentlich
druck den gehen die maßnahmen bisher
nicht weit genug wir wollen was die
menschen draußen dazu sagen wenn diese
im pflicht dazu tatsächlich kommen
sollte
ich bin geimpft also wäre es ja für mich
jetzt erst mal keine einschränkungen und
dann muss ich aber auch sagen das ist ja
eigentlich auch der richtige weg um auch
da rauszukommen sonst ist das ja wie
einer dauerschleife und im januar geht's
wieder los nächstes jahr im herbst
geht's wieder los ich bin kein gegner
der allgemeinen pflicht wenn die
ordentlich eingesetzt wird das heißt mit
ausnahmen für leute bei denen es partout
nicht geht dann sollten wir das denke
ich im angesicht dieser notlage machen
dürfen ich bin nicht für eine
impfpflicht weil ich sage jeder mensch
sollte selber entscheiden dürfen über
seinen körper was er macht und was er
nicht machen ich damit um dass ich die
allgemeine impfpflicht für gut halte in
unserem land damit die impfung auch nach
oben geht die quote und dass das für die
für das allgemeingut natürlich eine
positives zeichen ist diese situation
geht es wohl keinen anderen ausweg geben
und die leute die so viel
einschränkungen die nehmen müssen bloß
wegen der umkämpften das ist nicht in
ordnung ich bin absolut vier impfen ich
wäre froh alle menschen würden es tun
dass wir unsere freiheit unser leben
wieder zurückbekommen ich habe überhaupt
gar keine angst aber eine impfpflicht
ich denke ein stück weit sollte der
mensch schon selber entscheiden können
ich finde so allgemein kann ich das
nicht sagen
also keine allgemeine zustimmung aber
auch umfragen haben das gezeigt zuletzt
hierbei bild eine insa umfrage die
mehrheit der bevölkerung 58 prozent ist
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht da wo
wir doch mal hören was die bald
opposition dazu sagt wir sind verbunden
mit dem stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der cdu/csu
frei
hallo guten morgen nach berlin hallo ich
grüße sie herr frei also der künftige
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat gestern
hierbei bild live zuerst an kündigt er
möchte eine impfpflicht haben er möchte
dass die abgeordneten im bundestag frei
ohne fraktionszwang nach ihrem gewissen
darüber abstimmen können und zwar noch
im dezember ihre meinung dazu
also ich will ganz offen sagen dass ich
da sehr skeptisch bin ich warte es immer
was das thema hat allgemeine ängstlich
anbelangt und ich bleibe es ich will es
nicht vollkommen ausschließen weil es
natürlich klar ist dass die impfung uns
helfen kann eine fünfte oder sechste
welle und damit eine endlosschleife
dieser pandemie zu vermeiden aber ich
glaube das entscheidende ist dass wir
jetzt vor allen dingen alles dafür tun
und die impfquote in der bevölkerung
markant zu erhöhen und da darf man
glaube ich nicht der illusion erliegen
dass das allein dadurch geschieht dass
man eine impfpflicht anordnet denn das
haben wir ja bisher auch gehört bei der
durchsetzung dieser impfpflicht gibt es
ganz unterschiedliche meinungen und wenn
man nicht bereit ist den konsequenten
schritt zu gehen dann wird eine
impfpflicht alleine nicht ausreichen das
heißt wenn ich die unterbreche herr frei
sie waren an der regierung sie hatten
lange lange zeit das tempo zu erhöhen
sie haben es nicht geschafft ganz
konkret die frage wenn es zu dieser
sitzung im bundestag kommt dieser
abstimmung darüber endlich ja oder nein
frei nach dem gewissen der abgeordneten
wie werden sie stimmen
also ich kann es noch nicht abschließend
sagen aber ich will eindeutig sagen ich
bin sehr sehr skeptisch und eine
impfpflicht kann immer nur eine ultima
ratio sein dh es muss klar sein dass
dann davor alle anderen maßnahmen
ausgeschöpft sind und der erste schritt
wird ja eine bereich spezifische ins
nachweispflicht sein das halte ich im
übrigen für sehr viel effektiver und
sehr viel vernünftiger darüber hinaus
ich hatte es bereits angesprochen
flächendeckend zweig in praktisch allen
einrichtungen die nicht lebensnotwendig
sind das wäre aus meiner sicht klügere
weg und ansonsten ist es so muss man
sich die konkreten anträge anschauen sie
haben es im bericht auch gezeigt dass
hängt dann von außen haben ab die
statuiert werden und anderes mehr ich
kann es also nicht abschließend heute
sagen aber ich bleibe skeptisch bei
dieser frage auch weil ich nicht davon
überzeugt bin dass man auf diese weise
das ziel gut erreichen kann weiteres
großes thema gestern bei dem interview
mit unserem wald kanzler olaf scholz war
ja eben auch wie lange geht man denn
eigentlich als geimpft er olaf scholz
sagte dazu gestern man könne eben nicht
20 jahre lang als geimpft gelten wie
stehen sie dazu wann muss man sich
boostern lassen und ja wie lange geht
man eben als vollständig gegen kroner
geimpft
ich glaube da muss man sich an den
wissenschaftlichen
evaluierungen orientieren und da haben
wir in der pandemie gelernt dass wir
permanent dazu lernen wir hatten die
erwartung dass mit der zweiten impfung
ein dauerhafter impfschutz erreicht wird
jetzt sehen wir in zahlreichen studien
und untersuchungen dass der impfschutz
eben je nach wirkstoff nach einiger zeit
nachlässt und wenn man von vollständig
geimpft spricht dann bedeutet das eben
auch dass man über einen entsprechenden
immunisierung status verfügt und über
einen entsprechenden schutz und wenn
sich herausstellt dass dieser schutz
nach fünf bis sechs monaten so markant
nachlässt dass man nicht mehr von einem
vollwertigen schutz sprechen kann dann
gehört die auffrischungsimpfung
selbstverständlich mit dazu und dann
muss man die auch verlangen wenn man von
einem vollständigen in schutz er frei es
gibt erste stimmen die auf massive
kontakt beschränkungen für geimpfte
fordern unter anderem
mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsidenten manuela schwesig
fordert dass heute morgen ist das ein
weg um die pandemie stärker einzudämmen
wie stehen sie zu massiven kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte
ich würde es jedenfalls keinesfalls
ausschließen ganz im gegenteil ich bin
davon überzeugt dass man so etwas jetzt
sehr schnell braucht denn das
diskutieren über die impfpflicht das
heißt dass die tatsache wenn sie sagen
schon dass es unter wenn sie sagen dass
man das jetzt schnell braucht dann
skizzieren sie das doch bitte mal etwas
konkreter also sind wir wieder dort wo
wir im letzten jahr waren zwei haushalte
insgesamt maximal zehn personen also
auch für geimpfte
also fakt ist dass wir jetzt ganz
schnell die kontakte um 70 bis 90
prozent reduzieren müssen und das
bedeutet beispielsweise dass es keine
fußball bundesliga spiele mit zuschauern
mehr geben kann das bedeutet
beispielsweise auch dass bestimmte
aufzüge versandten irgendein
veranstaltungen nicht stattfinden können
hinter jetzige zeigt das bedeutet auch
dass bars und diskotheken aus meiner
sicht nicht offen halten können und das
gilt dann selbstverständlich nicht nur
für die ungeimpften sondern für alle es
geht darum jetzt massiv die kontakte
nach unten zu fahren aber auch und es
ist immer noch ein kind das auch nein
sagen frei einmal auf die nachfrage was
heißt das für den privaten bereich
treffen wir uns dann auch als geimpfte
nur noch im kleinen kreis also maximal
zwei haushalte beispielsweise und zehn
personen nein also was geht kontakt
beschränkungen den privaten bereich
anbelangt glaube ich ist es tatsächlich
so dass es auf den impfstatus ganz
erheblich ankommt ich finde all die
maßnahmen die man ergreift wir müssen
natürlich nachvollziehbar sein für die
menschen die müssen wirken wenn sie
ansonsten nicht überzeugen können dann
werden sie auch keine akzeptanz finden
dann wird die cola bekämpfung politik
insgesamt keine akzeptanz finden
deswegen bin ich sehr dafür dass wir uns
auf das konzentrieren was wirklich auf
wirkung entfaltet und das bedeutet
insbesondere kontakt beschränkungen im
öffentlichen raum für alle und ansonsten
konsequente umsetzung von 2g und zwei
gibt
ganz konkrete noch einmal nachgefragt
sie sprachen vorhin von bars und clubs
nicht von clubs und diskotheken bars
darunter fallen auch kneipen nach ihren
begriff das heißt auch kneipen müssen
wir dazu machen
ja aus meiner sicht ja fakt ist dass es
dass das infektionsschutzgesetz wie es
derzeit gilt nicht hergibt sachsen und
bayern haben entsprechende maßnahmen auf
der grundlage des alten rechts ergriffen
und deswegen ist unsere zentrale
forderung auch dass der deutsche
bundestag schnellstmöglich zusammenkommt
um erneut die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite festzustellen damit
die maßnahmen die von den
landesregierungen für notwendig erachtet
werden auch tatsächlich umgesetzt werden
können vielen dank herr frei für dieses
interview für ihre zeit